قلت هيئه الاركان المشتركه لوزاره الدفاع
اليابانيه انها حامله الطائرات التابعه
للبحريه الصينيه ليونا بوصله المزيد من
نشاطها العسكري في المحيط الهادي في
الثامن والعشرين من الشهر الجاري وتوجهت
الى غربي جزيره غوام التي تضم اكبر مركز
للجيش الامريكي في المحيط الهادي بين
يوميه الثالث والعشرين والخامس والعشرين
من الشهر الجاي وبحسب الهيئه فقد بلغ عدد
المرات التي حطت فيها الطائرات المقاتله
والمروحيات حامله الطائرات اليونج واقلعت
منها يوميه 17 وسبع والعشرين من هذا الشهر
حوالي 260 مره
من جات الاخرى قال الجيش الامريكي ان
طائره عسكريه صينيه نفذت في الحادي
والعشرين من الشهر الجاري مناوره غير امنه
في بحر جنوب الصين قرب طائره عسكريه
امريكيه ارغم قائدها على المراوغه لتفادي
الاصطدام بين طائرتين
الطياره
من الطائره الامريكيه